looking for some life hacks oh we got  you covered look at this if you're a  candle hoarder upcycle your vessels by  using this hat pop them in the freezer  and use a butter knife to get out the  wax you might have to work at it a  little bit but usually they just pop  right out  there's a handful of ways to do this but  we found this way to be the easiest we  just pop them in the freezer and do them  in bulk if there's any leftover wax  residue we just use a little goo gone to  get it out sometimes the vessels are the  reason you buy the candles and they're  just too cute to get rid of so repurpose  them that's  genius why didn't i think of that  [Music]